really here today to talk about this
place which is the epitome of
apprenticeship schemes this country
needs lots of engineers it needs
scientists and this particular facility
for example term will turn them out and
that's what we that's what we need in
the country more facilities to enable
people to actually be at work ready
years ago 50-odd years ago the word
apprentice actually meant that you had a
bit brace on and went into some
engineering works we know that we have
lost out quite a lot on manufacturing
facilities like this here are here to
train people to start that manufacturing
regeneration again and that's why I'm
here today yeah it's great to see it
about today just tell us a bit more Lord
Sugar about what's on offer there what
kind of skills is adjust engineering
skills where's science biology we've got
electromechanical engineering here
behind me you will see some equipment
that the students have made themselves
or using which simulate robotic
manufacturing I visited a bunch of
students today we were sitting there
with their soul during irons solder and
printed circuit boards which took me
back about fifty years it's a it's a
great facility it is an unbelievable
facility here and I think you know I've
got to thank Harringay together with
Tottenham Hotspur Football Club we've
had a lot to do with this I mean without
them and a few other sponsors this
facility would not have been available
it's I've opened lots of schools in my
time and lots of and visited lots of
universities and this is actually real
leading-edge technology here